hello everyone and welcome back to the
semifinals of the world fish random
championship this is a round two well
game two to be exact
Fabiano quranic verses verses magnus
carlsen is the same position that we
already saw in Game one now Fabi with
the white pieces you already know
everything that we mentioned in the
previous video so I would just like to
mention that yes I also realized that
the player would the white pieces is
sitting on the white chair but as it was
only the first game I didn't know if it
was if it had any relevance but as in
the second game they were also sitting
on the color of their pieces so I guess
that's that's how they did it but you
know congratulations to all so to
everyone who figured that out so getting
back after the game Fabi with the white
pieces opens with d4 and Magnus and not
unlike Fabi in the previous game sorry
about that Bobby went f6 Magnus goes for
f5 okay yeah we have Knight the d2 by
Fabi Knight to c6 and now comes c3
probably both of their seconds figured
something out during the games improved
on the on the variations a bit so here
for the second game are both of them
know a bit more than they did in the
previous one Bishop to g6 by Magnus and
now already a very very nice principled
move by Fabio for saying that this
Bishop is now a funny looking Bishop you
know being being part of this pawn chain
here and also it's a very interesting
how Carson will develop the dark square
bishop so for the moment - two very bad
bishops with d5 by Carlsen and the now
comes g4 you don't really gain anything
by capturing so here we have E six
defending the f5 pawn with nice the e3
now with a triple attack on the f5 one
and only now Magnus captures with F cat
person g4 Queen captures on g4 end here
for betrayed than g1 Bishop captures the
rook captures okay one of the bad
bishops is no more on g6 for Magnus with
Knight the e7 for the moment there's
this pin here on the e6 pawn so even
Knight captures on d5 is a threat Carson
house has to deal with it so nice to e7
guards the d5 pawn and also
prepares the pulled the c-pawn so the
bishop nbh finally comes alive the ship
the age for by Fabi end now Knight G to
f6
sorry night F to g6 attacking the bishop
and also defending the knight on e7 Fabi
trades once and now f5 trying to try to
well trade on f5 but also to weaken the
d5 pawn so across and strengthens the d5
pawn and also now the bishop comes alive
it is not a very good Bishop now with
castles by Fabi it's it's a short castle
but you know if you look at it it looks
like a long castle but it's actually a
fourth castle so far B castle short
ending out g5 by Magnus already starting
an attack on the kingside he wants to
push h5 which will come with a wooden
attack on the Queen so he will be able
to push his pawns much faster and Fabi
plays f6 a very interesting line where
now the night is under attack but Magnus
first attacks the queen with h5 there
was the interesting line Bishop to f4
before h5 as it attacks the night and e3
this will fall with check so you have to
go for Knights to g2 and then offer this
trade did this for this but then black
can still push h5 queen of three and
then go nice to g6 seems like a well it
just maybe maybe a small improvement but
cousin prefers h5 without developing the
bishop at all so first h5 pushes the
Queen back but now Fabi pushes f7 Fabi
wants to trade Queens here we have h
captures on g4 f captures and g8
bringing you a queen into the game with
Czech Knight captures and g8 not rook
captures Magnus wants to keep the rook
on the H file he wants to bring this
rock over to h3 so he doesn't mind a
rook to f8 check as he says the King
will just move and it's it's not a
problem even though the King can even
move here to d7 and then you also have a
threat Bishop captures for example on h2
with Czech can pick up the rook on a
fate and the ideas like that and Fabio
Greece he plays Knight to g4 and now
Bishop to d6 now guarding the f8 square
the king will come into the game maybe
even castle and then well the game
continues with Knight to f3 going after
the g5 pawn and now Knight the h6 by
Magnus
with night captures rook captures and
now not capturing on g5 and allowing
this trade on h2 as the bishop in the
rook or attacking the h2 pawn but rather
the Knights the e5 here we have kinked
the c7 preparing to bring the other rook
into the game and now rook the f7 check
kink the b6 by Magnus and now look beat
f1 the Fabi doubles up on the F file
with the shocked after Sonny 5d captures
only 5 and now rook a to h8 preparing to
capture on h2 so look 1 2 F 2 4 B
defense and now g4 now preparing to
bring the rook over to h3 and try to
create weaknesses on the Queen side for
the moment it's a very strong one but if
you can get maybe a 5 a 4 and a 3 and
you could maybe weaken it
we have rook 7 to f6 now offering a
trade and here Carlsen just moves it
back rook to h3 he offers the pawn here
but grabbing it right away runs into g3
so you have to calculate a lot here not
something you want to allow black for
example H captures rook captures with
the check now you can go here because
the rook h1 checkmate so you have to
block with the rook and only then rook
to e3 and ok it's it's a pawn up for
white but it's a double D pawn you can
always play a rookie for it's it's not
an awkward you know spot for a rook
once you get to e4 it's a perfectly fine
position so after rook to a3 we look to
g2 fabi doesn't allow g3 and now comes
Luke the e3 I'm going well going after
the pawn but not really as fabulous rook
captures on e6 so across and gives up a
pawn for the moment but his his rooks
are much more active for the moment with
a 5 and here kink the f2 you don't want
to grab this guy then you lose all of
all of the well d2 point and the Queen
side pawns as well so King to have to
first look the e4 now defending the g4
point and now rook to e7 not allowing
causing skin to go deeper into the
position as the b7 point is under attack
and also you're making room to start
pushing your passed pawn so rook to h5
cousin is now ready to pick up the e5
pawn and the now comes
King bee one first look back to h3 and
now East six he doesn't like to go for
all the trades and then lose his G for
pawn he prefers to keep keep the
position intact and keep his active
looks with Easton's by Fabi Bobby starts
to push his past pawn this is what you
always must do with past bones and a for
now hoping for a three to create some
weaknesses here on the c3 pawn with a
three by Fabi of course not allowing it
and now kinked a6 either preparing to
push the b5 pawn or if white plays
something else like rook to e8 what
Bobby did now the King no longer has to
guard the b7 pawn now the king can start
marching down the board Bobby of course
is preparing to push the point even
further with King to b5 by Magnus and
now the situation on the clock is 9
minutes
Bobby and 13 minutes cousin so here
Crossing is a bit a bit up on the clock
and they yet still have to make eight
more moves so e 7 by Fabi and now rooked
h7 it's it would be unfortunate for
Magnus to go King to see for it it seems
like a great idea
King c4 to b3 but if you do this white
wood white would win the game here so
you can even pause the video and try to
you know take advantage of this silly
mistake that never actually happened
well I give you a couple of seconds for
those who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
rook and game player and for those who
just want to enjoy its rook captures on
g4 I've seen this happen really really
often in classical chassis in you know
any types of tournaments so you know you
have to know this now you have to
capture the rook because the ones the
rook moves your route will not be able
to go up and down as the basically pin
so you'd have to capture the rook and
then look the a 8 now prepares the Queen
the pawn and you have to give back the
rock you have you you cannot give back
this rook because the rook captures and
then with check and then you pick up the
rook and then you just Queen the points
you have to block with this rook and
then you just get rook captures on a4
with check first King to b3 now you
capture this guy with
allowing to capture on e7 our rook
captures on e7 and after rook before
check you also defend your B to pawn so
after King moves you would have five
points at the three points and most
likely a winning winning rockin game so
you can start marching down the board
just yet so we look to h7 by Carlsen and
now look the g8 so offering a trade of
the e pawns for the Jeep on with rook H
captures on e7 by Carson and now rook 8
captures and g4 and now kink the C for
preparing King to b3 Fabi Tracy or a
pair of rooks rook captures D captures
and not h4 Fabia again starts pushing
his passed pawn and III by Magnus so
it's a bit of a problem for Coronas King
as currently you can't really move it
anywhere now you know you have to be
careful about any background ideas okay
for the moment there aren't any but you
know anything can happen we look the g4
by Fabi with check King to b3 not ready
to capture on b2 but maybe not just yet
as you would lose the a4 pawn so look
the b4 check first Fabi takes it with
tempo King - see - and now rook captures
on a4 and the situation on the clock is
17 minutes Fabi now 7 minutes Magnus and
I think the first time I misspoke cousin
was always lower on time so sorry about
that but it's already a move 39 so they
each have to make one more move until
move 40 so King capture some B to buy
cars and this is move 40 and both of
them now reach time control and Fabi
starts pushing the passport with h5 King
captures on c3 for Magnus and now h6 and
here
rook to h7 across and play this and I
will mention this because it's it has
something to do with the title of the
video why homework - h7 but I will only
mention it after the game yeah I will
mention it after the game so roof to h7
going after the pawn and here Fabi
defends it with rook to h4 so of course
not interested in trading this very
strong passed pawn and here Carlsen went
b5 I just started to push his past once
he wants to get
five in c4 maybe c5 was was even better
as fabi's main defensive resources is to
bring his skin into the game this way
the problem with c5 right away is that
it's much faster for example King f1 now
c4 you can just move the King start
pushing it all the way so it's hard to
say if if c5 or or b5 would have been
better here but okay b5 for Carson with
King to f1 this is the only good
defensive idea for Fabi c5 now and
rooked h5 going after one of these pawns
but now see for allowing allowing fajita
to grab on b5 but then he loses the dh6
pawn and the situation on the clock is
ten minutes Fabi 13 minutes Khalsa now
so now it's a far because lower on the
clock with King to g2 preparing King to
f3 and now kink the d2 now going after
this pawn king to have three of course
defending if you trade here rook after
some b5 king capture Sonny to than the
two past points that will be too strong
so kink the f3 this is what I was
mentioning earlier maybe if Carson
started pushing the C pawn instead of
the b-pawn maybe this defensive resource
would not have been available for Fabi
but they were both very low on the clock
so you know you have to make moves we've
see three for Carlsen now already this
is a very dangerous pass pawn rook the
d5 with check King to c1 and now here
Fabi has to defend his hh6 pawn and he
should have defended it would rook to h5
and it's a he definitely would rook to
these six but it is just it's not or as
simple as that but it's you know again a
principled idea to put a room behind the
past pawn and we often see a very very
strong players miss this idea of course
it's never this simple but you know it's
just more often than not that that it is
correct so look the b6 was played at
defending the the pawn this way but now
cross and just plays c2 so he's ready to
move the King and Queen his pawn
Fabi please look the b6 now attacking
the the b5 point but now keep the d2 now
threatening the Queen depandi
we're not going to be to where Fabi
could pick it up with check so foggy
plays Rock the d6 with check we have
King to c3 and it was in this position
on more 51 that Fabi resigned the game
why did he resign well whatever you play
here you could start checking rooks e6
check but then you reach the B 2 square
and now you made a full circle and the
white is not in time white the white
rook is not gonna be six to pick it up
with check so here you don't really have
a good option if you try rook captures
just to capture Sun h6 and you can't
even capture the rook because check this
comes with check and you pick up the
rook here so you would have to play real
captures on c2 but here White has no
counter play and even if you don't start
checking with rook to c6 check there is
no good alternative King f4 still just
king b2 next move you Queen the pawn so
really just amazing how how such a such
a wild game can you know it all ends up
here where you put the room behind the
past pawn or rook to d6 but there we
have it that's that's how chess is and I
also mentioned that I will explain what
I meant
when this looked h7 was played here in
this position no that's not that and
that's not the position here when Carson
played rook to h7 this Norwegian
supercomputer says I said that c5 here
completely winning for black who knows
why we'll never know but then Carson
played rook to h7 and everyone was like
oh yeah he messed it up but then after a
few seconds assess AC valuation of rook
to h7 went to plus 70 so again giving
completely winning for black so that
that's why I thought it was a fitting
title for the video faster than say say
so I do hope you enjoyed that as well so
that's the second game car across and
was able to bounce back and equalize so
tomorrow two more classical games and
then we'll see what happens then and we
also will be checking up on some games
between an echo and Wesley so from the
other matchup of the world facial random
championship so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Michael Bogut and Robert Kieffer
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here think of for
watching and I will see soon
continuing with everything we're
covering at the moment and of course
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day